سفر برلك مرحمه او ملحمه دراميه تاريخيه
من اضخم اعمال هذا الموسم الرمضاني وهو
المسلسل المنتظر من سنوات وبدا العمل عليه
المخرج الكبير الراحل حاتم علي وكملوا بعد
وفاته المخرج الكبير اللي مسلسل بيحكي عن
مرحله مهمه جدا في التاريخ اعمال تطرقت
لها ودور من اهم الادوار في العمل هو
شخصيه عبد الرحمن اللي بيلعبها الممثل
السعودي عبد الرحمن اليماني الشخصيه هي
لشاب مثقف عنده مبادئ ومعتقدات وثوابت
محدده في الحياه وبحب فتاه اسمها هند
واللي بتقوم بدورها السعوديه ميلاء
الزهراني ولكن بين جبر انه يخضع للعادات
والتقاليد وبيتزوج
هل ستغير الاحداث شخصيه عبد الرحمن
وين عبد الرحمن
[موسيقى]
اليماني اهلا فيك عبد الرحمن وكل عام وانت
بالف خير
حياك الله يا ساره وكل عام وانتم بخير
والمشاهدين بخير وكل سنه وانتم طيبين
ومبارك عليكم الشهر جميعا علينا وعليك
ويعني مبروك العمل ومبروك البطوله
بس خلينا قبل ما نتكلم عن العمل تحديدا
احنا شفنا في اللقطات يمكن اللي عرضناها
الان واللي بيتابعوا المسلسل شعرك مختلف
تماما عن اللوك اللي انت عامله الان يعني
ايش سر الوضع ايش صار يعني خليني اقول انا
اقول لك اول شيء العمل تصور تقريبا قبل
سنتين والله كتب انه ينزل الان فعده سنتين
فتغيرت تماما غير كذا انا فعليا فعليا من
الناس اللي يحب شعرين فابغى اشوف اي طريقه
الام مو غير اني احلقه لانه ما شاء الله
لما يكون واقف كانه ياشر من بعيد ههه
المدام ظفرته قلت خلاص تمام
يلا لقيت
حل خلينا نرجع
اللي هي انك صورته قبل سنتين يعني
اول شيء احكيلي اصلا كيف بدا هذا العمل
معك انا عارفه انه كمان لقصه مع الراحل
حاتم علي اذا تحكي لنا عنه
اول شيء كنت في مصر
تقريبا ايام كورونا 2020 كنت بصور عمل
وكلمني الاستاذ فراس دهني الله يعطيه
العافيه واحب اعطيله يعني احلى وامسه احلى
امسي عليه الله يسعده كلمني عن الدور
وتقابلنا انا وهو وتقابلت مع الاستاذ حاتم
علي انا اصلا استاذ فراس لمن كلمني في
البدايه قال لي انا اعرف انه انت تحب
الاستاذ حاتم علي قلت له هذا صحيح قال لي
طيب هو طالبك يبغى يقابلك عشان دور في
العمل لما رحت قابلت الاستاذ حاتم علي
لما نقول لك كذا قبل ما تروح تقابله رده
فعلك ايش كانت
انا ما صدقت يعني حرفيا ما صدقت قلت له
استاذ فراس استاذ حاتم علي يعني طلبني
بالاسم قال لي ايه انت بالاسم يعني ممكن
انا اكون من المرشحين
قلت له طيب رحت قابلت استاذ حاتم علي وانا
فعليا ماني مصدق يعني دخلت
لقيت نفسي بتكلم عفوا وقلت له استاذ حاتم
انا حرفيا عندي كلمتين نفسي اقول لك هي
ممكن تعتبر ناس تعتبرها ابتداء او اي شيء
بس هي في قلبي
فراس دهني ضحك وقال لي هي كلمتين انا
حافظهم بدي اقولهن مثل ما هن قلت له مضبوط
قلت له استاذ حاتم انا احبك وامي تحبك
وابويا يحبك وكلنا نحبك كل العالم كل
العالم العربي يحبك يعني اعمالك لا زالت
موجوده القديمه والجديده وبصمتك موجوده
وتمثل لنا جزء كبير من حياتنا يعني كبرنا
على مسلسلاتك
ابتسم معاي وجلست بعدها تكلمت انا وهو اول
لقاء بيني وبينه انا كنت بيني وبين نفسي
والله العظيم انا اشهد بذهني لحظات واقول
انا بتكلم مع الاستاذ حاتم علي يعني
كانت لحظه للتاريخ الله يرحمه الله يرحمه
الله يرحمه الله يرحمه
بعدين ايش صار يا عبد الرحمن
تكلم معاي عن الكركتر وتكلمنا عن جوانب
الشخصيه انا كنت اصلا بمثل في دور ثاني
ابدا اخلص عشان اجي اسمع حضرته واتكلم
معاه كمان كان موجود الاستاذ ليث
الله يسعده
قابلنا وتكلمنا عن الكركتر ايوه تكلمنا عن
الكركتر فهمت منه بعد كذا اعطوني الحلقات
ورجعت قريتها بعد كذا طلبت من استاذ فراس
دهني اني ارجع قبل الاستاذ حاتم علي
والاستاذ عشان نتكلم حسب ملايات يعني كيف
شفت الكتابه ايش شفت ايش فهمت الكركتر ايش
كذا لانه مشكلتك كامل كانت خمسه حلقات
مبدئيا فقريتها ورجعت طلبتها الاجتماع
واجتمعنا
اديت مرئي للاستاذ حاتم علي الله يرحمه
الاستاذ ليث تكلمنا عن الشخصيه واتفقنا
على المقاطع اعطاني توجيهات واستاذ ليث
كذلك اعطاني توجيهاته
وكانوا يعني مركزين معي جدا انه ترى العمل
لعبد الرحمن ما هو سهل العمل ضخم ولا
والعمل ضخم ضخم والدور مهم جدا ويبغى له
تركيز عالي يعني حتى الله يجزاك خير
الاستاذ حاتم علي واستاذ ليث والاستاذ
فراس ذهني قال لهم دور كبير في في يعني في
تذليل العقبات اللي كنت بعدي بيها كنت
مبسوط جدا بالتجربه زائدا متحمس زائدا
كبشر كان عندي نسبه خوف بسيطه انه هذه في
النهايه مسؤوليه العمل العمل ضخم زي ما
اقول لكم شايفين
بدي اسالك على هذا الموضوع عبد الرحمن
يعني العمل ضخم طبعا عامل ضجه وحوالينه
جدل والكلام هذا كله ليش تحسوا انه مهم
انه نتكلم عن هذه الحقبه من التاريخ يعني
وخصوصا في عمل درامي يعني يعتبر موضوع
ثقيل يعني
ايا كان كل شخص من حقه انه يتكلم في
التاريخ ما عاد بالك ان كان تاريخك وتاريخ
بطوله وحادثه حصلت امام العالم العربي
والاسلامي
جميع في ناس معاصرين هذا حدث تاريخي ما
عاد بالك في قصه بطوليه لك في سواء من
ابناء القبائل او سواء من سكان اهل
المدينه هي قصه كبيره حصلت عندك في تاريخك
من حقك تفتخر بها من حقك تصورها من حقك
توريها الناس
واتمنى اتمنى اتمنى من الله حقيقي انه
احنا نكون وفقنا
مبدئيا المسلسل في بدايته واتمنى انه نحن
بدانا نوري شي للجمهور يكون مناسب رغم انه
الحمد لله ربي اكرمنا انه في كثير ردات
فعل ايجابيه اللهم لك الحمد الجميع اي
والله اللهم لك الحمد الجميع مبسوط الجميع
مرتاح
فاتمنى منكم قدمنا اتمنى نوصل الحلقه
الاخيره ان شاء الله ونكون قدرنا نوصل
فعليا الاجواء حقت هذيك الايام القصه
الناس تستمتعون بالروايه كامله بالعين
ونتمنى نتمنى من الله التوفيق حقيقي لا ما
شاء الله هو فعلا عامل ردود افعال كبيره
وحتى كثير ناس يعني خلينا نقول من دول
عربيه مختلفه جالسين كمان بيتابعوه
باهتمام عبد الرحمن هذا العمل بالنسبه لك
نقله نوعيه يعني عمل كبير ضخم انتاج ضخم
بطولتك بعدها ايش ناوي تسوي
والله
سؤالك سؤالك مهم جدا الله يسعدك طيب انت
انت قلتي للواحد المفروض يعني فعليا يبدا
يفكر فيه دور زي هذا
في توقيت زي هذا في في قصه تاريخيه مثل
هذه تحتهم للانسان انه يكون في في يعني في
قراره شويه دقيق اتمنى انه ربي يكرمني
اقدر احافظ على هذا المستوى اللي وصلت له
وتطور الى اكثر من ذلك في النهايه هي فرصه
عظيمه جاتني الين عندي اتمنى انه ربي يكون
وفقني فيها
الاختيارات بعد كده يعني هي حتما حتكون
محدوده كل فنان انت عارفه كل فنان وله
منظوره وكل فنان له سكته وكل فنان له
طريقته يمكن لو تشوفي انا من يعني من ايام
حتى الشيخ عملتها مع مجموعه ام بي سي في
2016 الله يذكرون بالخير من 2016 تقريبا
انا عملت مسلسلات فقط مسلسل دون ومسلسل
وادي الجن بحاول قدر الامكان بشوف اللي
يناسبني بشوف اللي يناسبني في النهايه هي
خيارات والواحد بيعتبر كل اختيار تحدي
نتمنى من الله التوفيق ان شاء الله لا ان
شاء الله من نجاح لنجاح نحن بنشكرك على
هذه المداخله وبنقول الناس طبعا يكملوا
متابعه العمل لانه في المزيد من الدراما
كمان جايه كان معنا من جده الفنان عبد
الرحمن اليماني شكرا لك عبد الرحمن
[موسيقى]